in this video I'm going to be editing
your copy that's right I went on Twitter
I posted and I said I want to edit your
copy and I got a bunch of responses and
so what I did was I took all your
responses of people who submitted email
copy to me I put them all in my notion I
picked three randomly and today I'm
going to walk you through those three so
I'm going to copy Chief those live we're
going to Dive Right In we're going to
read them together this is my first time
reading them live so this is going to be
my initial thoughts it's going to be fun
but it's going to be quick and dirty and
I hope you get a ton of value but before
we dive into the rest of the video if
you are a copywriter which I presume you
are then I have a free gift for you 63
cash cow copyrighting tips that you can
read in 90 seconds or less it's my
copyrighting guide called copyrighting
Catalyst it's in the description below
all you got to do is click the link put
your email in and I will send it to you
instantly so that way you can get some
of my best copyrighting tips today all
right now that you've got some free
stuff let's go ahead and dive into the
first email that we are going to be
editing all right so live on your screen
and I'm going to be looking at my
computer over here live on your screen
we have some copy from uh I believe it
is redim yeah redim down here so we're
going to be going through some of his
copy gave us some insight by the way
when I say editing we're going to be
editing his copy we're going to be
giving feedback back so we're not going
to be in here rewriting or anything like
that but we're going to give feedback so
that you can go back and rewrite your
emails to your people so that they can
be better all right so coming in right
here let's go ahead let's let's read it
off the top and let's get some of that
high Lev feedback uh right off the rip
okay so the target audience is Muslim
creators pretty cool awesome what I sell
is coaching to help Muslim creators grow
and monetize their brand I like that
Niche I don't see many people going
after that Niche so that's cool I also
have a free school Community uh call
Muslim creators that's very clear okay
awesome and about half my subscribers
are from there fantastic awesome okay so
I'm assuming the subject line right here
is free app to go viral in 2025 and the
preview text I'm going to space this out
just in case you didn't the preview text
I believe is found a free app that's
been helping me go viral okay it's 5:51
on a Sunday what on Earth am I doing
sitting parked in my grandparents
driveway with the engine running wearing
only my PJs okay I like the story open
uh I'm hooked that's what I found a free
app that's been helping me go absolutely
viral recently okay I see I see what you
did here I can't pull myself away from
it I'm like a crack addict escaping to
get my fix no I'm not talking about
threads but yes my account has been
going uh consistently going viral okay
so let me stop you right here here's one
thing that I I do like that you did is
it's 5:51 on a Sunday I love this like
Gary Halpert style opener where he
always opened his letters with like 738
on the patio uh looking out my boat and
what it does is it creates this imagery
uh in This Personal Touch of where you
are which I love so so kudos to you for
for that one uh the thing that maybe I
would have changed especially now that
I'm looking at it like this is a much
longer email right like look at this
okay so this is a much because I saw you
already had some content going on okay
and we'll skim this cuz cuz I I can I
can tell I already know where you're
going with this okay so so with this
being a much longer email you went from
story to pitch like really quickly so
quickly that I don't think there's no
way you're going to be able to deliver
this much content and keep people's
attention if you're going to pitch 90%
of the time so you started with a story
let's let's see where you go before
before I judge this too much but but you
really got into the pitch really quick I
found a free app can't pull myself away
from it I'm like a crack you're selling
hard honestly it almost feels like one
of those infomercial like Brian ma where
he's like and you won't believe it like
you don't want to go so hard so quick
unless that's what you're doing and if
that is what you're doing I would have
made this email a lot shorter like if
you're like hey here's the app bada bing
bada boom 1 2 3 4 5 hope you love it
click the link like if you're going to
sell hard I would keep it a lot shorter
but if you're going to story sell which
I thought is what you were going to do
story sell meaning you were going to
pull me into a story make it really
interesting hook me for a long time
appetite my desire right where you incre
where I'm like oh my gosh this was so
entertaining this is so fun you take me
down a rabbit hole and then you sell me
that's where I thought you were going
with this but let's keep going let's
keep going cuz I have a framework that
might actually help you with that okay
so 2.8 million views 3.5k followers I
would have loved to have said I was
going to say what at cuz you said I'm
not talking about threads but my account
has been consistently going viral what
account I'm I'm going to skim this a
little bit because I see what you're
saying okay so now you're selling the
app you you selling viral now it feels
like you're selling me to get on this
app getting warmer and then and then you
tell me got it okay I see what you're
doing you're you're having fun here all
right now I'm getting to the point
here's what I was trying to figure out
is do you go back into storytelling or
are you just going to keep on selling so
you were selling all the way from like
line five all the way down to like the
pen and then you said but wait what am I
doing in the car okay you waited too
long
to go back into your story okay so
here's here's the approach that I would
have taken if I were you I would have I
would have used the SLO framework
instead of for this so SLO is story
lesson offer story lesson offer it's
what I use for my daily emails and I
would have told the story from the car
up front captured their attention and
kept their attention going taught a
lesson from that story and then made the
offer so basically you're you're hard
selling up front on this very long email
which is really hard to keep their
attention what what you could do instead
is tell the story like here for example
if we go back up here what on Earth am I
doing sitting uh parked in my
grandparents driveway with the engine
running wearing my PJs only maybe you
could go into a story that's like well
I'm here because I was broke for the
longest time I tried this whole Creator
economy thing I was posting every day I
invested in all these cohorts I paid for
all these courses and guess what none of
them freaking helped me I didn't know
how to do any of this I was posting I
wasn't going viral nobody was growing on
my email list nobody was buying my stuff
and it was really hard okay so you see
what I just did I created a story and
now that story has Stakes like there's a
reason there's a bigger reason I'm
sitting in the driveway and it's because
there's a problem there's a big problem
the problem was I tried this other thing
and it didn't work okay so now I created
a story I've captured their attention
and the lesson is you can you could then
tie to a lesson right so this story
lesson offer if we're going to go to the
lesson then the lesson is the thing is I
was blindsided to what wasn't in front
of me and what wasn't in front of me is
I've been in this Muslim Community for
the longest time and they have been
using this other app that they've been
going viral on so I said what the what
the heck am I doing on threads and
Instagram I should be on this with my
people Muslim creators focusing on I
could go viral here instead I don't know
if that's true but you see how I'm
playing that and then then you make the
offer so I got on this app and I my
account started going viral I started
you see how we went from story there was
a problem right the stakes were all so
hard and then we then there was a lesson
you learned something you were
enlightened and when you were
enlightened the thing that got you from
uh a when it was really hard to B when
it was not so hard was your product so
your product introduces the
transformation that they feel and you do
it in that order cuz if I'm looking down
right here you went back into
storytelling you've already lost me
either I'm going to buy the thing or I'm
not going to buy the thing so if you
sell me sell me but if you're going to
story sell me make the story
significantly more intriguing okay uh
and then I see that you're teaching some
lessons at the end but but yeah I would
take that I would tighten it up I would
use that SLO framework entertain a lot
more if you're going to keep me on a
long email um but yeah other than that I
hope that is really really helpful I
would take that um yeah let's go to the
next one all right next email that we
got here who is this from this is from
Sam all right Sam let's dive into your
email so subscriber first name Allan I'm
Allan so I'm going to read it like Allan
Allan I get paid to eat breakfast no
really let me explain okay I like that
uh see last Sunday as usual I woke up to
the sun shining through my window no
alarms needed because I make my own
schedule it was I don't know if you talk
like this it was 9:36 a.m. so I got on
with my morning routine boy likes to
sleep in I like that hot shower fresh
coffee inspiring podcast delicious
breakfast out in the sun I like this I
like the imagery I'm in I'm in the
bedroom it's 9:36 a.m. there's fresh
coffee uh I would maybe tweak that a
little bit like hot shower I would I
would use better verbs right here like
steaming shower a fresh pourover Co I
would I would make it a little bit more
enticing it is simple it's nice it's
easy to read I would specify that
podcast too listening to a huberman podc
like bring some personality in here cuz
I could almost write this like delicious
breakfast out in the sun not delicious
breakfast eggs and bacon in the sun
specificity right right uh then ping
stripe $2500 for S okay all right all
right I see where this is going this is
fun a reel from a few days ago hit
30,000 views and brought in a brand new
client sick okay awesome however unlike
most business models I didn't have to
run ads okay I like how you're pointing
this out okay so that you got a solution
you got a client from from reals or
whatever you were doing yeah reals you
got a brand new client from that um but
you're pointing out what you didn't do
the problem I didn't have to sell cheap
Chinese products I didn't have to do any
cold Outreach okay I like that you're
addressing objectives that your Market
typically has okay I simply created a
reel with my proven step-by-step content
structure posted it on Instagram and the
client came to me with $2500 in hand I'm
going to come back to that I'm going to
come back to that uh Allan at this stage
of my content Journey this happens three
to four times a week at minimum and now
after giving this step-by-step stra uh
framework to my students it's happening
to them too take Martin for example okay
I like how you use a case study take
Martin for example who couldn't figure
out why his content wasn't the hitting
the algorithm then after creating just a
few reals from my framework one of them
blew up and he signed a brand new
high-paying client yes the client saw
his video DMD him and sent over this
payment no cold Outreach needed now he's
consistently growing his personal brand
week after week and getting ready to
onboard even more clients so if you're
fed up with inconsistent growth and a
lack of inbound clients and you want to
start getting paid $2,500 while
demolishing while demolishing your eggs
and steak see that's the spe specificity
right there demolishing your eggs and
steak breakfast in the morning click
here to book a call with me and I'll and
I'll show you how to help okay talk Sam
FYI this is not a sales call uh it's
just see how I can help you achieve your
goals and the consistent that PS I would
just be honest FYI this is a sales call
this is absolutely sales call like the
you're not giving out free calls for the
sake of just helping you're literally
saying click to book a call with me so I
can help you and then you say FY it's
not a sales call don't do that that
feels a little like mismatch probably a
little sleazy here's what I would say as
far as this Emil okay so honesty is
pretty well written um the structure the
flow it's it's it's not too long but but
you started with some imagery you kind
of started with the story you went into
the pitch and then when you went into
the pitch you didn't keep me too long
where like the first email with redeem
redeem tried to keep me in this like you
know 800w email but he was already
selling me by like the third sentence so
it's really hard to keep my attention
this email being shorter but gives me
the image you overcome my objectives uh
I mentioned some of the specific at the
beginning here's the big underlying
thing that I would focus on in this is I
actually don't believe your email a real
from a few days ago hit 30,000 views and
brought in a new client okay I've heard
stuff like this before uh but the BS
radar on creators and copywriters and
people nowadays is just so high based on
reading stuff like this because they've
also tried it now you're you're going to
try and tell me how I run like most
businesses I didn't have to run ad blah
blah blah I simply created uh a Rio
following my proven step-by-step content
structure okay your proven step-by-step
content structure is easily swipeable by
like anybody anybody can say I have a
proven step-by-step content structure
but if you tell me something more
specific like my proven TLC 4 content
structure I just made that up but right
that sounds legit out of curiosity my
proven 434 content structure you give it
a name give it something you don't have
to give it away and in fact what I would
do is not only give the name away I
would tease what you do differently I
wouldn't give away the form of what you
do differently if this really works but
the fact is you're telling me that this
happens three to four times a week
meaning you make $10,000 a week because
$2500 stripe uh clients are are banging
your account meaning you're making 40K a
year off some reals it's just it's just
not believable right like I know the
marketing Bros online are saying that
this and that it's easy but people's um
people's suspicion radar is higher than
ever because they've bought all these
courses they've bought these cohorts
these content strategies they try them
it doesn't work and then they don't
believe anybody anymore and so you need
to do reason why copy reason why copy is
you have to give them a reason why your
thing works and not the other thing that
they bought from hundred other people
reason why is well I used this TLC
framework and in our TLC framework what
we did was we actually got an engineer
to hack the Instagram algorithm and when
they hack the in Instagram algorithm
they found three pieces in their code
that identified what makes reals go
super viral as fast as possible and what
doesn't do you see how I just made this
significantly more compelling because
now you believe me I said it's a
specific framework and the way we got
the framework was this we did this thing
where now um we had a code engineer go
in there find something in the algorithm
that we've pointed out that we are now
taking advantage of to leverage and
that's why our reels are going viral to
the right people and so my content
framework takes advantage of those three
algorithm code Snippets that we found
and now your content can too now I
believe you at least a lot more than I
did believe you when I first read this
and believability is the first part of
sales because they have to believe they
have to trust you you're selling
yourself as much as you're selling your
copy so I think the copy honestly pretty
good um but I would I would change the
way that you structure your offer how
you teach your offer and how you get
people sucked into your offer but uh
nice job overall all right all right
last email email number three let's look
up here this is a DIC email is that the
do you mean DTC or do you mean like the
framework dis is it the disrupt Inspire
click I don't know either that or maybe
you meant DTC but anyway all right so
audience are people who want to learn
copyrighting or copywriters who want to
up their game and make more money oh
good this audience I'm very familiar
with all right let's go I wrote this
email for copy Squad okay and it crushed
their average metrics for their list
well that's good okay so now I'm I'm
very interested the product is seven
pages to seven figures okay seven pages
to seven figures that's what we're
selling here all right subject line 20
years old 40 million in sales here's how
okay all right I I already get the Vibes
that we're going to we're going to talk
about what we talked about in the second
email uh oh this is a short email this
is not far okay well let's check this
out okay un freaking believable a
20-year-old intern went from $0 to $40
million in sales all he did was F oh man
okay all he did was follow the fstep
money maker copy blueprint uh this
proven framework helps you make the sale
in the first few pages of your copy to
realize your shot to maximize your shot
at generating seven figures and royalty
checks this system works whether you're
in financial bizop dating or any of
other Niche you could think of and no
matter where you look on the internet
you won't find this special Brew plant
anywhere else so if you want to maximize
your shot at crafting money printing
copy that drowns you in seven figure
royalty checks click here now for your
only chance to maximize your shot at
generating seven figures peace out copy
Squad okay um I'm curious what the copy
was before this that this one blew it
out of the
water uh it's not it's not it's not
horrible copy but uh it's it probably
encapsulates the thing that the second
email that we just went over and capsu
it's like I have zero reason to believe
this okay the 20-year-old intern what's
his name who is this guy like there's no
specificity in this 20-year-old from 0
to 40 million and how long in the client
sales in in what Niche selling for 40
million for himself selling for somebody
else like if you would have said uh two
weeks ago we hired this intern Zach okay
Zach came from Chicago he moved over to
New York uh for the first time to start
riding for uh for financial services
here um we're we're very much like a
financial aore whatever copy Squad
whatever it is okay his first couple
sales letters absolutely completely
bummed I mean like he literally shipped
them and there was crickets absolutely
nothing then he sat down with our copy
Chief Zach when he sat down with our
copy Chief we're like dude you haven't
even learned the five-step money maker
part why are you writing sales letters
do you see what I just did I just turned
a real kid a real person who I told a
little bit of backstory he moved over
there okay so now you believe okay Zach
moved to New York he tried a couple
sales letters completely tanked there's
problem there their stakes and I said
dude you haven't even learned the fep
money maker Pro you see what I did I
interjected your product into the story
without selling the product I'm because
I'm talking to Zach there's dialogue
there's action it's Dynamic uh you
haven't even learned this what the heck
is that why didn't anybody show me this
okay yeah so it's this thing where if
you nail these five steps in a sales
letter you're about 100 times more
likely to actually generate some sales
okay so I want you to go back to your
desk study this mechanism okay study
this five set framework do not come out
of your desk until you've mastered this
thing rewrite these sales Pages rewrite
the sales pages and then we're going to
ship them again okay so then he goes
back to his desk he slaves all night he
sleeps under his desk I literally wake
up the next morning I bring him some
McDonald's coffee and a and a McMuffin
I'm like Zack are you okay he's like
dude I've been studying this thing you
told me you said I can't leave until oh
my gosh did you study it did it work
well I don't know I spent all night
rewriting the sales page so we shipped
the new sales page I'm making this whole
thing up we shipped the new sales page
and Bam he generated 2 million off his
first thing then he did it again the
next day generated 5 million because uh
obviously us at copy Squad we have the
biggest list possible so he did have
leverage you're going to have to explain
the 40 million I'm saying we have this
biggest list possible that's reason why
copy reason why he went from0 to 40
million is because he took advantage of
the framework and he had a big list and
he worked with us and whatever it is
right this proven framework give me a
little bit more context obviously my
story was longer but you can shorten
that down uh add some specificity to who
is this 20-year-old intern where did
this money come from and tease me a
little bit on the fstep money maker what
is the five-step money maker copy
blueprint and then one other thing you
said down here is uh you won't find this
special blueprint anywhere else why not
copyrighting has been around for 100
plus years and there's blueprints all
over the place there's there's Eugene
schwarz's Market awareness Market
solution there's Ben settle's fstep copy
Sage bundle there's um Tom Benny's sixf
fig sales page okay all of those things
exist what what tells me the five-step
money maker is better than those guys
who have generated Millions right it's
really hard for me to believe some
20-year-old intern kid who's never
written copy in his life or I don't know
if he's written copy can take this very
very simple five-step uh money maker and
that I cannot find this anywhere else
tell me why you can't find this you
can't find this special blueprint
anywhere else because it was written by
David Deutsch himself and he came in and
we paid him hundreds of thousands of
dollars to actually coin this Mentor our
people and I don't know right like David
maybe you did write this um but at that
point you're giving me some reason why
it doesn't exist uh and then by the way
I would use a I would use a PS I I like
ps's I would do something at the end
that's like down here if I'm coming down
I'm saying PS uh this offer expires or
blah blah blah give them give them a
deadline something uh that makes it uh
more enticing to to click the link I
love ps's um so I would do that there I
like how short it is uh unfreaking
believable that's a great way to to
start out of line but anywh who yeah I I
I would say I've read a lot of emails
like this especially in the copyrighting
N so if you're going to Target
copywriters I think you need to be
slightly more believable we kind of
whiff it nowadays where you can smell
something you're like I don't think so
so yeah any who that's the three emails
guys that wraps us up if you found this
video valuable it would mean the world
to me for you to like it and subscribe
to the channel and if you specifically
like breakdowns like this and you want
me to do more drop a comment down below
and say hey I'd love you to do more and
honestly you could Twitter message me uh
some of your copy I'd be happy to uh
store it for the next video uh you can
email me you guys know my email and if
you're not already on my email list of
course you can go to Allen drag.com join
that email list I appreciate you guys
thank you so much
I hope this helps and don't forget grab
copyrighting Catalyst before you head
out it's completely free Link in the
description below I hope it helps you a
ton and now I will catch you on the next
one